قال يا مراسل الجزيره المقاتلات حربيه
اسرائيليه شنت غاره تهدفت موقعنا المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وسط قطعه غزه
محمد على ما يبدو ان الطائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لا زالت تحلق في سماء القطاع
وتغير على عدد من الاهداف في مدينه غزه
سمعت ذويه عده انفجارات قويه في مدينه غزه
الانباء الاوليه تتحدث عن قصف
لاحد مواقع التدريب التابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه جنوب هذه المدينه لكن حتى الان
لا زالت الطائرات تحلق وربما يكون هناك
المزيد من القسم الاسرائيلي القصف السابق
كان استهدف احد مواقع المقاومه ايضا في
وسط قطاع غزه على الطريق الرئيسي صلاح
الدين بحسب المصادر الامنيه كطائرات
الاستطلاع اطلقت عدد من الصواريخ بالاضافه
الى
صواريخ ايضا اطلقتها الطائرات الحربيه
المقاتله
سلسله القارات الموقع
واحدثت اضرار كبيره في هذا الموقع وايضا
المناطق المحيطه به وهناك ربما خلال هذا
الوقت تجري ويسمع اصوات همم ذهبت الى
مناطق القصف لتمشيط تلك المنطقه والتاكد
من عدم وجود اصابات همم لكن في الغالب
وفيها كذا حالات لا يكون همم ربما اصابات
لانه همم تجري عمليه اخلاء لجميع المواقع
التابعه المقاومه وايضا همم مواقع الحكومه
والشرطه ووزاره الداخليه تحسبا لتعرضها هي
الاخرى لاي عدوان اسرائيل محتمل وهذا همم
عدم وجود اصابات جراحه هذا همم
من القطاع هل هل هنالك الصواريخ اطلقت بعد
هذا قصه عن اكثر اكثر من من قصب المناسبات
هي اكثر من غاره في الموقع الاول الخمس
الاجراءات على الاقل حتى الان نفذت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه غرتين على
موقع جنوب مدينه غزه ايضا ولا زالت تحلق
الطائرات
كما تحدثت هناك صفرات انذار اطلقت في ااا
مناطق غزه لكن من الواضح انها اطلقت بسبب
اطلاق كتائب القسام والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
همم
صواريخ ارض جو على الطائره المغيره وربما
هي همم هذه المشهد ان اعتدنا عليه خلال
الفتره الاخيره ان تطلق همم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه همم الصواريخ بالاضافه الى
المضادات الارضيه باتجاه الطائرات التي
تتحلت في صنع القطاع وتقص وتغير على همم
بعض همم هذه المواقع لكن بكل الاحوال همم
حتى الان تبقى همم الاوضاع هذه الصاروخ
الذي اطلق في وقت من مساء امس هي ضمن
قواعد الاشتباك يعني كما اعتدنا عندما
يطلق صاروخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه مناطق
الغلاف القريبه من قطاع غزه تغير الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه واراضي زراعيه
وطالما لم تكسر
الطائرات الحربيه والجيش الاسرائيلي هذه
القاعده فربما يتوقع ان لا تكون هناك مزيد
من الصواريخ باتجاه المناطق الاسرائيلي
شكرا لك شمساقوت مراسل الجزيره من غزه